he's happy to do this for the LSU campus
he'll be on tonight
covers the rest of the state so welcome
I know that there are some people who
are connected online so for everyone let
me know if you have any questions I'll
be here otherwise I think it's time to
start thank you everyone
my name is Delia Brodsky I'll be doing
an overview today of what we will try
and cover in the next several months and
I want to start off once the lights are
figured out good so the goal of this
program is to really bring together
people that come from different
backgrounds and I think that's both an
opportunity and a challenge we've
learned from the previous time when we
started doing this is that we have to
learn a lot about how to adapt to
materials with different types of people
that are interested and so we're hoping
that this will be a learning experience
for all of us for you and for us as well
because we would like to see and
understand from you more about how to
make this more useful and effective for
you to do that I think we have a great
team that wants to kind of facilitate
this task and there are some people here
today I don't know some of you are
probably familiar with dr. Kim Kim who's
here John
Sahil from our side so or
Linden I think cocktail is in the room
somewhere so it would be good at some
point for all of you be familiar
these people because they're all here to
help make this work for you so let me
start by saying that the main reason why
this was put together is because there
is a growing gap
okay so there's Linda who is going to be
helping us connect between the LSU
campus and the people that are online
okay so there's a growing gap between
the data that is generated and our
ability to process that data so there's
a lot of data that we can generate in
the lab and then it's not so clear you
know how can we use this effectively and
what we can do with that data and to
bridge that gap we are trying to look at
the different stages where this can play
a role where this can have an impact and
this really spans the life cycle of data
and I think it's critical for everybody
who's involved in specifically as we are
a part of the lvr n the biomedical
research network program and we're
focused on the biomedical projects so
it's important to kind of see this in
the biomedical data lifecycle of theta
and where we have the people that
generate the data and they have this
task and this goal of generating more
and better data and then we have people
that have to analyze the data and they
have to understand if you forgot to have
des share so are five so table are not
seeing
they're about that
remote sites should now have a session
okay so we'll go back a little bit then
what we started saying what I started
saying is that there's a growing gap
between the data that is being generated
and our ability to effectively use that
data and to close that gap it's
important to involve everybody in the
process of learning about the data about
its significance about how its generated
about how it's used and that spans the
lifecycle of specifically biomedical
research data right so there are people
that generate the data that have the
goal of generating more and better data
because that's critical for our ability
to understand what's going on the people
that analyze and integrate that data
they have to be able to understand where
it's coming from and where it's going to
to design better methods and to improve
their ability to integrate the different
datasets and then eventually this data
is used in critical decisions and this
is critical for research for our basic
understanding of what's going on as well
as translational applications how it's
used for clinical decisions and for
other decisions that impact how we use
the data so it's important for us to
connect the dots to make this a clear
process and for everybody to be informed
and able to practically understand and
appreciate what happens with that data
and where it comes from and where it's
going so to do that we've put together
this program and I should say that the
program is still in development because
we're learning as I mentioned at the
beginning how to put together the
different pieces but what I want to do
today is share with you kind of where we
are with our understanding of how to
make this effective and hopefully
throughout this six months we will be
able to identify this
pieces and can hear back feedback from
you on how to make this better but today
just to give you an overview of what
this includes so the idea is that kind
of vision for this actually started at
the tower bioinformatics Research Center
which is a bioinformatics Research
Center at University of Haifa in Israel
they created a functional platform with
the vision of giving people easy-to-use
access to analytical tools for all kinds
of data and the idea was to make
processing of that data analysis and
integration and easy tasks so that
anybody could do it what we eventually
realized is that easy-to-use tools is
not enough
you really have to supplement that by
two more things and the two other things
were tutorials or modules we call them
modules and that talked about the
different types of data and projects
because in every case you have to have
an example project to really understand
what's going on and how a data set is
formed so as a result we have a
collection of tools or sites that we
will look at today and try to implement
in this program so the educational
modules that came out of this platform
and are consists of these different
modules that explain the logic of the
analysis so we call them omits logic
because they really take different onyx
data types and they explain the logic of
what to do with them where they come
from
I don't analyze them how to interpret
them and they are kind of centered
around your personal progress so again
the reason they are modules is because
this is not a standard textbook class
where you know everybody has to do this
anything it's really up to you which
modules are useful for you or
interesting to you and so hopefully
you'll be able to
pick and choose from the menu and create
your own program as we move along so
because of that or to finish off that in
every module there will be a number of
projects that you can also select from
these are going to be on various topics
and with various types of data these are
just some examples and as I mentioned
before this program is going to be a
little bit more on the biomedical side
even though I imagine that there are
some people involved in the program that
you know have a different focus but we
will use examples from the biomedical
field and a lot of them are going to be
in oncology so they're all taken from
publications and we kind of digest
little sections of the datasets that are
published translate them into small
exercises and then the reason why we
feel that's a good approach is because
you can then take the rest of the data
set or you can take another part of the
data set and make it your own so two
known fact publications only report you
know a small percentage of what was in
the data and so therefore there is
probably you know 90 to 95 percent of
data that you can still do something of
your own with and I think also a lot of
them and this is a good example of this
publication here they actually
themselves rely on other published
datasets right so it's how you collect
the data and what you can do with it and
what's your focus that makes it your own
so our hope is that at the end of this
you will be able to do what some of the
other participants did last spring and
in the summer where we ran similar
pilots this was the pilot at University
of La Jolla and then in the summer of
course we did the LV RN training where
groups of students were able to take
some these data sets and come up with
our own idea
and then share that with their mentors
and kind of guide it to an interesting
direction so our hope is that throughout
this course some of you will come up
with these project ideas and hopefully
during the annual bioinformatics
[Music]
bioinformatics conference some of you
will be able to share what came out of
this course hopefully what public or
your own data so the idea is to really
go through the logic of the analysis
provide you with the tools provide you
with some example data sets to guide and
get the process started and then as we
envision the future of this program you
know maybe some of you will decide to
actually use these resources develop
their own projects out of this and and
then we will see more data driven
projects in in different research areas
so what we kind of see as a part of this
program is providing access to tools and
enabling infrastructure and I think this
is this cover is not just what we do
here but but in general maybe that's the
objective of the Louisiana biomedical
research network is that this is not
just the course to kind of complete it
get it and you know get a certificate or
a credit for it's really to introduce
you to these research infrastructure
solutions that are available and
exposure to kind of how is this done in
different examples in the different
districts and then provide an
opportunity to kind of take that into
your own direction and take it into a
variety of projects that either we
curate and we put up as an opportunity
or or start with your own so the goal of
the program is to introduce people that
are interested to the resources
available
go through the LVN to provide access to
tools and methods for data analysis to
help develop independent research
projects to leverage public domain
datasets and then to facilitate
meaningful collaborations and by
meaningful collaborations I think what
we've seen in the past in the summer for
example is that we will have students or
faculty with different backgrounds and
biology and then others with computer
science and more technical skills and I
think that real exciting opportunity is
when those join forces and they decide
to work on a single project and that
project gets fun along because now
people can speak the same language
because it's clear what the biologist is
trying to do and it's clear why you know
somebody with computer science
background could be really helpful to
take the project farther but it doesn't
happen you know right away I think there
is a big barrier here too to cross and
and we hope that some of the material
that we prepare will help us to
establish kind of one framework and and
then throughout these breakout sessions
or workshops that we will organize we
will try and work through some examples
and learn about how these different
components fit together okay so what are
the specific resources that we will make
available throughout the program
the first one is user-friendly tools and
methods
so by user-friendly this is a screenshot
I will give a short demonstration of
what the platform really does but it's
really a graphic user interface for
public domain tools that you can
download from github and other places
and you can essentially run wherever you
want right now throughout the program
you will be able to use our
platform that is kind of centralized and
we can help monitor what's going on
behind the scenes so that if there's a
problem we can make the problem go away
or at least address the problem and we
can also see how people are interacting
and using different tools which gives us
a sense of who is practically doing
things and who is involved it may be
just a more theoretical way the second
is online training modules so another
challenges you can imagine is that
people are in different locations
different schedules and so we want to
make materials available online and we
want to make these kinds of sessions
possible as well so what we will do is
we will have a series of online lectures
or modules and I think that it's very
important to try and at least look at
them so that you're familiar with those
concepts before coming to the workshops
then as I mentioned these will be
project examples and project examples
are really datasets with an explanation
typically a publication that explains
where the data came from what they did
to the data and what was their
interpretation of the results and we
will try to replicate every stage of
that process and at least give you an
idea of if you were doing the exact same
thing this is how you will do each one
of the steps and then obviously you can
take them to different directions and
then we have created this kind of a
community where we brought everybody
together so that you can know who else
is a part of the program so hopefully
you will see other people that you could
work on different projects together
eventually and learn from each other
from you know different backgrounds and
different people that are involved now
the other resources that we will touch
on or utilize some one are going to be
our studio so we're not going to go deep
into our studio or really
how do you know write scripts that are
but we will touch on that and we will
show you how to do simple things like
visualization we will of course use
Excel because I think we found that the
majority that people already know itself
well enough so that they can but you're
welcome to use any other scripting
visualization or dam management tools
that you want really what we want to
provide is just a framework of how to
get started the other part of it is open
public domain in a sense on NCBI that we
will take you know raw data from and we
will try and learn how to process that
data but it's important to note that all
of you will have educational accounts
which limit your amount of data that you
can upload so because we are supporting
about a 100 licenses here what we've
done is we've pre-loaded a number of
resources on the platform and everybody
can have access to those through
reference links so we will show you how
to download and upload those files onto
the platform but if you would like to do
that you would have to come to us and
ask to open up your limit and then
you'll be able to do that so just keep
that in mind it's possible but you do
have to kind of get permission to do
that and then finally we'll talk about
reference databases where we can
validate some of our findings right so
if we found some interesting pathways or
whatever and we want to validate and
other data sets we'll talk about how to
do that how to research other databases
for that so one of the things that we
will talk about is how the data gets
assembled and how to create a project
that you know will have enough samples
and will enough will have enough
statistical significance for us to kind
of base our hypothesis on and so we will
do some exploration of datasets
available events yeah so that you can
start thinking about your independent
projects if you do have your own data
that you would like to analyze I know
that I've heard from some people that
they are already thinking that you know
they could kind of do that throughout
this course like I said it's possible
just let's kind of try and coordinate
that so that we are aware of what
exactly you're trying to do and how this
could be useful to the rest of the
people that are participating in project
okay so let me demonstrate to you I
think all of you should have gotten an
email with credentials for the platform
and if you brought your computers maybe
we can just make sure that it works and
I will show you how to log in and have a
kind of navigate platform so that you're
aware of what's there and that's another
thing about these kinds of meetings and
workshops obviously this is the first
one and so we're just kind of learning
what this will be used like but in the
future if we do an in-person meeting
like this you know please tell me with
your laptops and and ready to you know
have the data set ready you have
whatever we set you ready and if you
don't have something working or you
don't have some links just be you know
there are some key people that are here
like Linda may think that could probably
help or Sahil was in the back here but
he's also unchecked so let me walk you
through some of the links that you
should have received by email so that
everybody knows what we're talking about
exactly
okay so the first link that you should
have gotten is this link server dot T -
bio info
I don't know if you can see it's right
there on top and what it is is this
platform called T bio info this is the
areas of analysis you should have all
that in an email with a with your login
information so as you can see this is my
profile so all of you have an
educational profile on the platform
again the link is server T - pile of
data info now if you don't have your
credentials with you today it's going to
make this visible on them between ok so
I know that some of you don't have
laptops sorry probably should have you
know told everybody that it would be
useful to have them with you today but
you know we're not going to actually do
anything practical I'm just gonna yeah
so everybody that was registered got an
email if you didn't get an email then
please write us so we know who to send
it to
I got an Evo but I didn't see the lake
yeah okay well let's just make sure you
know so we know who did anybody else not
get the wings okay so two people okay
yeah so that's good so let's try and
figure that out today I mean we'll have
some time today so come talk to me or
like I said living say he'll there in
the back can definitely say he'll was
the one that created all the accounts so
if you have any problems with that he
can help with that and the other thing
is that all of this is really on this
educational platform and let me ok so
there's an organization page let me
maybe start from here then so this
link is edu okay so I'll just copy this
here real quick so these are the two
primary links for us to start with the
edu site is where the educational
content is the server site is where the
practical methods are so please make
sure that you have accounts on both just
a note about their accounts they are
going to be there's going to be a login
so you use your email and you have a
password for both of those sites but you
should have gotten two different emails
about in fact okay so on the edu site
there's a whole page dedicated to this
organization called lv r m so this will
be organizations louisiana biomedical
research network LG iraq and here you
have most of the information that you
will need so you will see announcements
here about important events and
assignments and kind of what are we
doing this week or this month you can
also see an overview of the curriculum
that will show you month by month what
we are doing and where we are so today
we're doing introduction to
bioinformatics and then next week we'll
be doing introduction to RNA seek and
these are going to be the online modules
that you can look through then you will
see in December we will do epigenetics
and then we'll do a hands-on workshop
into RNA seek and then we'll start on
genomics in January we will have a
hands-on bioinformatics workshop etc so
you can really look through the planned
activities over here you also have a
page called faculty and that will shown
you all of the people that are
all that you can be in touch with so you
can see here all of the people that you
know if you need to ask about some
something that you can ask them right
here okay and then we will also attract
progress so you'll be able to see kind
of what is everybody do it
okay so back to the platform and the
second area that is more practical as
can be right here and what we will cover
are specific sections in this areas of
analysis so we will focus on the
next-generation sequencing data and we
will cover a lot of that so as you saw
in the curriculum section we will talk
about transcriptomics we will talk about
single-cell transcriptomics as well
we'll talk about epigenetics and
genomics so we'll talk about mutation
there again copy number variation we'll
talk about chip seek we will talk about
myself of DNA methylation and then we'll
also talk about metagenomics and some
non-coding RNA as well so whenever we
will do these different types of data we
will you know go through kind of the
background and then you will be given
the data set which is going to be a link
so I'll just demonstrate what that would
mean so for example the first section
that we will do is going to be
transcriptomics and each section is
built in a very similar way so you will
have the top section that is an input
what is the type of data that you're
uploading and so typically you would use
a reference genome with annotation where
the GTF file will talk more about it
when we start to transcriptomics module
and here you have parent their single
ends the type of input file that you
will have typically will be a fast queue
file and then a reference organism and
we'll try to use human genome as the
reference genome
then you will be able to upload the data
now I mentioned that for educational
users there's not going to be there's
actually a limit of 50 megabytes so you
can't really upload fast few files but
you can use this section called SPL
which is just a reference link or files
that are already uploaded and these are
called projects right so you can either
use multiple SPL links like this or you
can just upload a number of SPL links
together who URL upload so for example
you can go to you can just upload a file
and then as you press on this you will
see that a lot of fast queue files have
been already input into the system and
you can drag and drop them into several
groups for example if you want to get
differential gene expression or
something like that
or you can just cancel no groups and now
you can build your pipeline so again
like I said all of these methods a lot
of these methods are public domain
methods so if you search on google for
what is for example you know HT seek or
what is high stat - or what is bowtie
you can do that let's just quickly do
that bowtie again you can see right away
that you can use you can find the source
code and you can see what it is now also
in the process of doing that you will
actually get help in the system and
you'll be able to find all of those
things so you can see that now I have a
limited number of options available for
me those that are darker are the ones
that I can select so I can for example
build my pipeline reading about what
methods I'm using and more explanation
about the methods and that es behind
them are going to be given in the online
modules now he will have a reference
publication that you can read and a lot
of times that reference publication also
if you
the source code if you want to implement
that in your own pipeline so now I've
connected start and top half too and for
example I can use the standard cufflinks
hi planet so I can do cufflinks merge
and and you saw that each Papa tells me
what it is that I'm doing but in the
workshop we will kind of look at how to
set up the pipeline what would be the
input what would be the output and then
how do we interpret the results and so
the focus of the program isn't going to
be unnecessarily the code itself it's
going to be on what is the logic behind
this and so as you can see each number
of methods is organized in a group and
you can also read about what that group
does so you can see here the different
titles of the groups and now we can
click on them and read about what they
do so this is the platform and you will
see that there is going to be so once I
created by pipeline you can see that it
appeared right here and I can monitor
the status so since I didn't click on
the start it's only prepared but I can
always go back and that way I can
remember what exactly I was doing and I
can also run my pipeline now the
completed pipeline's
let me see something that though the
completed ones will also have output
files and we will talk about what is in
those output files and how we use them
okay so
why is this important well it's
important because if you go to Twitter
and you type in bioinformatics Hennig
you will see you know what really
happens in real life when you add a
tweet so this is the typical process you
know when you read about some newly
published tool that does this amazing
thing you take some time you find the
code finally you run it test it on a
small data set nothing works
and you forget about it right and so the
goal of the platform is to eliminate
this problem we do the curation of the
tools we go and make sure that they work
as they are described we try and work
through them with example projects and
then we prepare those occasional data
sets and then hopefully you know instead
of getting discouraged by other people
doing amazing things but I can't you can
actually see that you also can and then
you can take the things that are useful
to your own research and implement them
in your own way however is useful to you
so how are these modules organized so
the way that they are organized is that
we will have orientation workshops just
like today where we're not really doing
anything useful but we're just talking
about what we will be doing but we will
kind of give it an outline and so this
is the first module it's there is going
to be introduction to bioinformatics no
each one is about a week long so
introduction to bioinformatics is really
to test that we understand each other
you know there's not going to be a lot
of useful information for you I guess
it's mostly going to be about what is
bioinformatics in general and how is it
used in different scenarios but it's a
very theoretical you know a superficial
overview that's not going to be very
in-depth and it's just to understand
what are the different components so
here I go for the online modules there
you go for the practical things
and this is what I'm going to learn but
really what we're going to try and do in
the first month is cover transcriptomics
so how do we take next generation
sequencing files from aluminum machines
RAW files and how do we translate them
into tables of expression and then what
can we do with those thousands and
thousands of genes and so the those
consists of three modules
transcriptomics one two and three they
talked about processing data then they
talked about standard statistical
methods like t-test and what is
differential gene expression so we'll
cover all the things that we all know
about already but in the context of RNA
seek where P values most discovery rate
all of those things and we'll touch a
little bit on regression and then we
will talk about other methods how do we
do dimensionality reduction how do we do
PCA clustering and different things that
can help us mine that data and extract
something useful that then we can
interpret and how do we do them
annotation how do we convert the ensembl
IDs to gene symbols how do we do pathway
analysis and a gene set enrichment
analysis etc so we hope to do that in a
month and if you're already familiar
with processing how to run your you know
cufflinks pipelining and what is the
table of expression you can just skip on
to the next one because we will provide
the datasets within these modules at the
end of this process we will have a
workshop that is intended to help
everybody do the things that we already
did here but together in the session can
address any kind of questions or
challenges that come up and then at the
end your it's optional but you are
welcome to take one of the datasets and
really work through it so that idea is
that kind of bits and pieces but if you
can put the bits and pieces together on
your own that means you actually know
what you're doing and we will provide
you with just the
that in some direction on what you can
start doing with it but then it will be
up to you on how you complete yeah so to
generalize the question it was whether
different platforms to generate data
have an impact on how you analyze them
so we we will talk a little bit about
different platforms we're not going to
cover all of them but the bottom line is
that if you have a fast you file at the
end you can process the Basques you file
with the same tools you just have to
understand a little bit about how it was
generated to be aware of what would be
the specifics for example the length of
reads would be something specific to a
platform quality you know coverage
things like that so we will talk about
those things any other questions
any other comments okay so in also
online so if anybody has any questions
or comments online you can probably put
them in chat and and we will try to
address them to help you evaluate your
understanding and your ability to kind
of actually use this in the future
what we've come up with as a way to
assess everybody's level and progress is
to use the methods section of
publications so instead of just you know
tests or you know do you know what this
term is or that term is we will actually
take the methods section and the figures
from that sex
and we will ask questions whether you
understand what that means and we hope
to achieve two things by doing that
first of all because a lot of people
just skip that section right so we're
interested about what they did what they
said I have to do is what was the
significance and what they found but how
exactly you know that's where it becomes
technical and dry you know not everybody
wants to read through that but it
matters because your choice of methods
of how you
for example normalize the data or how
you you know chose one method over the
other is it because somebody told you or
because you tried many different things
that you chose one will really play a
role in the quality of the final results
and some some things that could have
been done differently to find
alternative results that are interesting
or reveal something technical about the
data so we will try and go through at
least several papers or probably two
papers in each module that will talk
about some of the standard processing
analysis interpretation steps and about
different concepts and these concepts
are going to have biomedical
significance so again for those of you
that have you know for example plant
biology background or interest and this
is not to say that you know that is less
important it's just that the focus of
the program is a little bit more
biomedical so this is going to be both
in the pre-assessment and the
post-assessment they're not going to be
exactly the same paper but the idea
would be that you know in the beginning
you will see how it's all the more
challenging to exactly understand what
happened in methods and then at the end
you will start noticing a little more
technical differences some people use
k-means clustering and others rely on
the hierarchical clustering and now I
understand what's the difference and you
know why they chose this and not the
other so that would be I think an
interesting experience that okay any
other questions
about the program or about the different
parts of online and kind of in person
the heel of John anything from the
online community yeah did you have a
question the one comment we've got is
seems to be pretty straight for all
right
so introduction to Bagram addicts the
what is - max bomb informatics is an
interdisciplinary field and we talked
about this already but it really
combines three major great thoughts we
have the domain which is biology and
then we have other Sciences there are
fields in their own right statistics
computer science and and these are some
other some other fields that have an
impact on violence relax the second part
of bioinformatics is that it really
started as a field of its own in about
the 1960s and so to get a perspective on
why that happened I put together this
little timeline on how we got you so in
the 1950s the DNA structure was
discovered and once that structure was
discovered right away people started
thinking well how do we assemble the
human genome so between the 1950s and
1992 by 2003 there was a rapid kind of
generation of data from the genome from
the DNA and you know it was a big
breakthrough obviously and today those
two people continue to kind of play a
role so one of
is that the director of NIH the other
one is craig Venter but then really what
happened was that Illumina brought this
power to generate this kind of data to
the masses right making it affordable
and making it possible outside of these
you know large government-funded
projects and that was in 2006 so in 2015
we already had 1,000 human genomes
assembled and you know that was again
published in 2015 that it was entering
the final phase the 1000 Genomes the
1000 genome project and then today in
2018 we have even more of that day and
we have thousands of genomes genome but
the idea is that we have a lot of this
data that is now available and as that
was happening so that was the story of
the human genome but really as that was
happening we discovered that the
relationship between gene and phenotype
is not as straightforward and that
actually is quite complex and so as a
result a lot of other types of omics
have started playing in emerging role in
bioinformatics and so bioinformatics as
a field really studies these different
types of omics data and what to do how
to bridge the information that we have
with the data that is has still not
become information it's still data so we
have phenomics which is the study of
phenotypes for example cellular images
we have the study of genomics so this is
an example of a VCF file so you can see
that the chromosomes and the DNA
we are represented by this data that
what is that well it's really how
individual nucleotides are changed and
their quality and whether we can call
those somatic mutations or germline
occasions or other things interestingly
in about 2009 there was an increased
interest in epigenetics so this is a
number of publications mentioning
epigenetic data so you can see that it
happened not so long ago but today we
understand the critical role epigenetic
modifications play in different
processes and those include histone
modifications as well as different
non-coding RNAs that modify how proteins
get produced and transcriptomics where
we study alternative splicing the
production of mRNAs and other types of
RNA so the whole transcriptome so the
field is expanding by different types of
datasets and obviously there's an
interest in integrating those because
even though we think we understand each
step of the process really we don't know
a lot about the missing pieces and so
the idea is that if we can know
something about one part of it and
another part is known from a different
types of data if we integrate if we know
how they are related we can then fill in
the gaps and so integration starts
playing a critical role and so today
what you will see is a lot of
multi-omics datasets that combine these
different types of technologies to
really understand both mechanistically
what's going on and to try to interpret
by leveraging what we know about one
data type or the other what this really
means the other part of bioinformatics
is really driven by these different
technologies that produce the data right
so we talked about this and
talk about the role of aluminum other
types of sequencers that made this data
available but these datasets are
specific to the technology that they
utilize and so understanding the
technology understanding the limitations
of that technology and the specifics of
that technology also is very important
because those results in different types
of datasets and that required processing
so as you can see these are fast FASTA
files which are just sequences and now
you have fast queue format that also
includes the quality of those sequences
but it's essentially the same thing and
so as you can see to really understand
something about it right so previously
like when the human genome was published
it was also printed in the series of
books and that's just unreasonable to
process and analyze and so people have
come up with different types of
processing pipelines like we saw an RNA
seek to take that raw data and translate
it into something that we can analyze
and so as a result what you will see on
the platform are these different
sections that deal with the machines
that produce the data and transferring
those into a readable table format and
so you know we mentioned others
high-throughput sequencing technologies
but also microarrays chip sync and then
RNA editing and so either different
types of data that we can extract from
one type of library prep or another in
the lab or different types of techniques
to actually generate that data energy
now another challenge that comes as a
result of this type of data is really
the challenge of data mining so this is
an example of a low throughput data set
a low throughput data set is simple in
the sense that you have only a couple of
variables for example
you have weight and size bought it in a
two-dimensional plot and here you can
really see the relationships between
these variables we're in onyx datasets
those relationships are really
non-trivial it's really difficult to
understand how are they related to each
other and what can this all mean in the
context of biology that is also not very
intuitive to us right so here we kind of
understand how size and weight should be
related and and it's easy for us it's
intuitive for us to interpret here it
takes a lot of domain-specific knowledge
and extracting that knowledge from
publications databases etc so
bioinformatics deals a lot with that and
so you can see how a lot of that will
come into play especially when we talk
about high-throughput it so
high-throughput data means that for
every sample you have a lot of
indicators and so you will have for
example tens of thousands of genes for a
sample or you know mutations per sample
or other factors going back to the
history at the same time around 2000 so
when the human genome project was
published you can see an emergence of
publications related to machine learning
and that is another development that has
really advanced bioinformatics but also
has made bioinformatics technically more
challenging for non computer science
people and on that math and statistics
people is to understand how do these
methods really help us what do they do
because a lot of them you know transform
the data in such a way that is then
difficult to interpret back in the
biological terminology or you know how
I interpret for example they mentioned
reduction and when I'm talking about
genes and expression and you know
nucleotides and things like that so
another challenge here is to understand
the analysis methods and to connect them
back to biology so because of that
throughout the course we will also make
this other course available that you
don't actually get an introduction and
it's not going to be its own module in
the sense that I showed in the beginning
but it's going to be an ongoing thing
that you can reference and it will have
different explanations of these methods
these machine learning methods so
they're going to cover things like you
know unsupervised analysis methods like
clustering dimensionality reduction they
will talk about classification and other
supervised analysis methods network
analysis and others in the context of
practical examples with biomedical
business so how do we use this I through
put these high throughput technologies
to classify different subtypes of cancer
how do we understand associations
represented by network analysis and
things like that so we hope that this is
going to be an additional resource that
you can rely on to understand better
than methods okay so do you have any
more questions so far about any of the
things that were mentioned up until now
okay so let me show you how these things
are organized again over here
okay so this is again just a practical
overview and the goal of the first
introduction to bioinformatics module is
to really get all of us on the same page
so if I go to courses right here you can
see that the upcoming courses are going
to be listed right here so I can go to
introduction to my informatics I guess I
should the introduction to
bioinformatics is going to start off
with a survey where you can help us
understand your background a little bit
better and please blow it out you know
help us adapt or future materials to
your level and then we will talk about
some of the things that I already
mentioned today so introduction to by
informatics is the field data-driven
discovery how do we go to from
hypothesis base to hypothesis free kind
of data mining approach to all these big
data sets there will be a practical and
a hands-on overview of the platform and
what you can do with it
and why it's useful what scenarios and
then we'll talk about some of the
biomedical applications of
bioinformatics how is this data analysis
significant or an impactful for
different challenges and projects in
healthcare and in other fields and then
there's a quiz so all of this is really
you know you can probably complete the
whole thing in 30 minutes but it would
be great for us to see you know what you
think about the length the time
commitment the level of the materials
and we envision that for some of you
will be really simple and probably not
green informative but for other people
that come from different other
backgrounds that might be useful
to kind of get everybody on the same
level so after you complete this then
okay so just practically how to do this
you have to enroll in the course and
then once you are enrolled you can go
into a lesson and just show what that
looks like so you will have your lessons
here on the side this is the survey
after you are done with the surveying
you have submitted it here at the bottom
you press on complete and after you have
completed you can then continue on to
the next so all of this information is
going to be useful for us also to kind
of see where everybody is that so that
we're not running ahead but and you see
that now it's green so I've completed it
and now I can go to the next one so just
remember to press on that complete
button and then at the very end once you
have gotten through the whole course the
whole module there will be a button to
complete the whole module so please
click on that as well and then the next
course that will come right after that
is going to be transcriptomics so I'll
just some of you might want to skip
introduction to bioinformatics if you're
already familiar with with that but
here's what we will do in the first
module of transcriptomics we will talk
about the biology of transcription and
some other methods to quantify RNA and
then we will jump into the hands-on
sessions which will include how to
generate the transcriptome expression
data so what are some technologies that
actually do this and how do we
understand them and then how do we
process them some different examples of
pipelines and then what can you do with
that expression table
but we will give you the table and we
will look at different genes expression
values etc so these are the very simple
first modules that everybody can start
with and hopefully that by next time we
will have this meeting everybody will
have all of their technical details
figured out and all of the accounts
workers okay so this is what I had for
the introduction to bioinformatics and
I'm happy to answer any questions that
you might have or if you have any other
specific things that you would like to
know about anything that I've shown so
far I'm happy so some of the materials
have been updated I have to say that we
update regularly the platform itself so
introduction to bioinformatics has been
only updated a little bit but there's
nothing new for people that you could do
it in the summer there are no
substantial changes on the other
sections we have been making updates to
the platform and to the modules
themselves but as a general rule I think
that people that have completed the
summer course would probably benefit a
lot more from going on to the other
modules that we haven't touched in the
summer yep these online modules for each
yeah it would be best if you could try
and do them before because what we found
was that during the session we want to
achieve
the practical results during the
duration of the session we only have two
hours and so it's good that you already
know what you're doing a little bit and
we could focus on kind of the not the
very basic technical challenges but the
more conceptual questions about why this
and why not that and how do these you
know relate to each other and really try
to avoid you know how do I open a file
in Excel or you know where do I find my
files or how do I connect two methods
together you know those types of
questions are all covered in the online
modules I understand that they could be
a little bit more dry just having to do
it in your own time but I think they're
fairly quick
so if everybody can try and go through
some of the practical things online
before coming to the session it would be
great we actually can see the progress I
think I think show you a little bit of
what that would look like but basically
we see on orange who is doing what at
least in terms of progress of these
online courses and your pipelines that
you are taking and so that helps us
really in two ways one is to see whether
specific sections are more difficult or
take more time for example where people
are having more technical issues with
those and then we can address that in
more detail and help everybody during
those in-person workshops and the other
way is to put together groups when we do
independent projects so in an
independent project obviously you want
to put together a group of people that
can help each other and that can make
the experience more smooth and so we try
to match people that have a little bit
more technical experience that we can
kind of see through analysis of the data
that we get and the people that might
have more insight into the biology and
the data set so that they can kind of
inform each other all done ah studio
Claire phone actually
analysis by playing solo so these are
the platform itself takes executables
that are written in different languages
and runs them through a series of bash
scripts they're really what it is is you
can have you know in script and R or
Python or and C or whatever it is and
then the bash scripts will just execute
them in the right folders with the right
reference files and libraries etcetera
so the platform will help dealing with
the big data sets and getting them to a
level that we can look at how we look at
them we can look at them in Excel we can
look at them in notepad we can print
them out we can use our studio it
depends on what's more comfortable for
you
we will do a little introduction into
some methods in our just because some of
the machine learning methods are like a
standard to line code in our and so it's
easy to run it and look at the output
and the input but we're not going to be
going into detail and I'm sure that
there are other more detailed our
courses that people can take or if you
have any specific questions you know for
example Linden I'm sure other people
here could help the havenaire be which
is not amazing oh yeah you actually do
not have to have our you know we'll just
kind of use it as a general example you
know this tool exists and this is what
it does and this is that you can create
a heat network well but we're not going
to be going into
yeah practicing yeah so yes if you have
any technical difficulties something's
not working or you don't know where
something is there's going to be a chat
box right here
and this chat box is going to be
consistent between the educational site
and over here for the server site so we
will respond within 24 hours of posting
that question there it would be good if
you can add your name and your email so
that we can understand whether you're
part of the elbe RN program or some
other program or you can reach out to us
by email and then we will get back to
you as well so we will try we will
answer questions like you know
something's not working you know I'm
having technical difficulties or a
specific thing and if there are more
general questions like what does this
method do or why this method and not
that method we will typically post an
answer in the forum so if you have those
kinds of questions because we want to
make them that available to everybody I
will just show that here so under lbr an
organisation which is right here
there's a form
so you can post you know if you have
questions on anything we just posted
right here and then we can submit a
detailed answer and then everybody will
have access to that
okay well if that's all the questions
yeah which of course is should we be
looking at it before the next session so
we will start with transcriptomics so
introduction to by informatics in
transcriptomics you don't have to you
know complete any of them before the
next session the next session is going
to be an introduction to transcriptomics
but if you do like transcriptomics one
it will be able to so the next session
is going to be again you can look at the
schedule right here what's that right
yeah so you can see that this is today's
or this is today's this is the next one
introduction to RNA seek so if I click
on this one you can if you're logged in
it will populate this automatically but
you can you know register through here
or register through the healthier end
website and then we will know that you
are interested in this again the point
of this is that there will be multiple
things happening at the same time so we
will start genomics right after that so
if you're more interested in mutation
variants and copy number variation sign
up for genomics your lunch then gene
expression sign up for transcriptomics
and so we'll have them parallel and so
that's why we're asking for people to
register where did you register register
for the events yes so you can either go
to this page which is the curriculum
page under the LB RN organization and
that will give you all the links in one
single place so for example I clicked on
this so these black ones are the events
and these are going to be your modules
so if you click on this that's how
I got to that event [ __ ] but also we
will post this link on the announcements
on the main page just so that everybody
has that
and then just a direct link where you
will see all of these once you're logged
in is if you just go to events the list
of all the events or if you want to sign
in for future ones you can see the list
right here
okay so I think we're done with
presentation we are going to be here for
a little longer so if you want to talk
to myself or some of the people that are
involved from the ldr inside the Hilo is
also here if you have any issues with
your accounts you don't know how to
login or you don't have your credentials
we can solve that right here right now
and of course if you want to just talk
to us and Dulles if you're interested in
doing an independent project as an
overall part of this program I think the
goal is to have at least a couple of
those independent projects so over the
course of the next couple of months
we'll be looking forward to hearing from
some of you if you actually want to
pursue that direction I just let us or
some of the administration you're from
CCP and Elba right now thank you
[Applause]